hi I'm Mike Massimino I was a NASA
astronaut for 18 years from 1996 until
I spent a grand total of about 30 days
living on board the space shuttle in
space over two missions it wasn't always
easy on the space shuttle it was fairly
small quarters there were seven of us so
we had to really be respectful of each
other like many of you sheltering in
place right now I'm inside my home and
it's it's kind of like being inside of a
spaceship again self-contained so based
on my nearly 30 days of sheltering in
space I have some tips for you that
hopefully will help you shelter in place
[Music]
embrace the situation I remember
learning this from John Blaha was an
experienced astronaut when I was a
brand-new astronaut he spent some time
on Space Station mirror and he described
his mission as almost like a first half
in a second half the first half he was
really missing home and really wasn't
taking advantage of where he was and he
realized that hey I'm here there's
nothing I can do about it I'm I'm inside
of this spaceship for a while he was up
there for months and the second half it
clicked and he said to himself I am
going to embrace the situation and take
advantage of where I am and make the
most of it and he said after he did that
he had a great time and the days just
flew by while I'm sheltering in place
I'm trying to take advantage of the
situation embrace the situation one is
I'm straightening out a little bit more
going through things that I haven't
thought I'd ever go through and I'm
trying to do that but also I'm trying to
take advantage of this new world we live
in we were communicating with each other
over distance my I teach at home
University I've been teaching my course
online we've been having faculty
meetings online and I'm getting to learn
how to use devices like this right now
using my phone and zoom and being a I
hope it's working by the way but I hope
I'm recording but I'm certainly learn
how to use these things now and they've
got young people some of my students and
my kid
trying to show me how to do these things
so I can continue to communicate and
send out messages and I'm learning a lot
I'm really all about Instagram and all
about ways we can communicate over
distance and I think that a lot of these
things that when this thing clears up
and were able to be around each other
again I'm still gonna be using these
tools because they're wonderful so
embrace the situation talk to Mission
Control and be somebody else's mission
control and what I mean by that is that
when I was in space even though I was
isolated from the planet I did have my
crewmates there but it did feel kind of
on my own I really fell on my own when I
went out to spacewalk I did have my
buddy my space walking buddy Mike good
with me but each of us were in our own
little spacesuits kind of like our own
spaceship and during my last spacewalk I
did four spacewalks on the fourth one is
the most complicated spacewalk probably
ever attempted we were trying to take a
piece of the Hubble Space Telescope
apart and something we weren't really
sure we could do well I made a really
bad mistake I stripped a bolt on one of
the science instruments and I thought it
was game over I felt like we're never
going to solve this I have created this
horrible problem and we're never gonna
find out if there's life anywhere else
in the universe and everyone will blame
me because it is silly mistake that I
made I remember actually looking at the
planet and thinking that everyone that
could help me everyone that I loved
everything was down there and I couldn't
I couldn't even get to a hardware store
to fix this problem it was like I felt
separate from from the earth but after
about an hour or so of troubleshooting
the ground mission control came up we'll
come up with a solution
you see wait for this
yeah we're ready the top half of that
handrail was freed by the fasteners
being released very easily the lower one
one of the fasteners did not come loose
and mike massimino used essentially
brute force to remove the handle at the
lower portion it is now free in a
solution work we were able to get the
telescope fixed that day the doors yeah
what a great job you guys did today and
I'm forever grateful but there was a
time when I forgot that they were there
to help me so don't forget that help is
always there we're in this thing
together and if you're feeling down if
you're having an issue a problem you
need help reach out and on the other end
try to be someone else's mission control
I also got a chance to work on the other
end of it one of my Jobs was to talk to
the restaurants in space but we call the
Capcom position in the control center
and they always tried to do what I could
to make my friends who are in space feel
more at ease particularly during a tough
situation
reach out be the person that people can
call for help
be there Mission Control and don't
forget your Mission Control is there to
help you as well
exercise exercise is very important in
space even on the short missions that I
was on longer missions it's really
critical because in zero-gravity there's
no load on your muscles you can lose
bone mass as well bone density can go
down if you're not exercising because
you're floating around on the space
shuttle when I was flying
we did have an exercise bike called the
ergometer and we're able to ride that
thing to get a little bit of exercise we
also had some Thera bands that we could
stretch out and get a little resistive
exercise in upper body even lower body
and I got the space log so we did a lot
of space walking and out was complete
exercise the whole time exercise I think
for our missions was just as important
for your mental well-being as for your
physical well-being and I think it's the
same thing here on earth at these times
I think it's really important to try to
get your exercise every day
whatever that means I've set up like
this kind of wacky sort of gym in the
basement what if you
weights and I don't have a I like going
to the gym that's not happening actually
to be truthful I don't like exercising
at all
but getting outside we can still run we
can enjoy the outdoors take the dog for
a walk take yourself for a walk it
always made us feel great in space even
just getting 20 minutes of exercise on
an exercise bike so get your exercise
enjoy the beauty around you I think
sometimes we get so wrapped up into what
we're doing what our tours are or tasks
or whatever it is that's occupying our
brain we forget to take a second and
look around and this happened to me on
my last spacewalk my fourth space law I
was done a little bit earlier than my
spacewalking buddy my good was was still
doing some work near the telescope and I
said well I said to myself I'm gonna go
to the airlock and start getting things
ready for us to go inside and while I'm
doing this my good friend one of my best
friends Scott all up in our commander
comes over the comm loop and he says hey
Mass that's my nickname because a mass
of what are you doing and I said well
I'm inside the airlock getting ready to
come in he goes is there anything you're
doing now that can't be done later I
said to him no I'm just trying to get
ahead he goes well why don't you stop
what you're doing and go outside and
enjoy the view and I thought that's a
pretty good idea plus my commander was
telling me to do this I thought it was
an order I had to do it you know so I go
outside of the airlock into the payload
Bay and they clip my tether in so I'm
not gonna float off into space I have a
tether hook on a handrail and I let go
with both hands and I just lay there in
the payload Bay of the space show and
looked at the earth I think it's really
important to enjoy the beauty around us
so take the time to enjoy the beauty or
if you really don't want to go outside
just stay inside watch something watch a
couple of Wired video something like
that some of my friends had to have
something to do and or we got delayed on
our landing by a couple days and I
thought this was the greatest thing at
the end of our mission because we had
nothing to do
for two days we got waved off because
the weather was bad we couldn't land in
Florida so we were stuck in space I
thought this was great and I just spent
all my time looking out the window
enjoying the beauty of planet Earth but
my crewmates they needed something to do
they were going crazy so they decided
they were going to watch movies there
was this one point in the mission at
toward the end there where I'm looking
out the window
we're coming it's nighttime we're coming
over Australia I can see the city lights
in Australia there was a thunderstorm
out over the ocean and I could see the
Lightning lighting up the clouds it was
just magnificent and right then one of
my crewmates Drew Froy still yells up
from the mid-deck he is a mess I know
what he says come on down they go why he
says we're about to watch natural Libre
you know the movie about the wrestling
well naturally break and I thought I
took so there's no way then and I said
I'll watch it when we land I'm looking
at something right now and they were off
watching Nacho Libre and I was looking
at the most magnificent sight that was
just outside our window so my
recommendation to you is yeah you can
stay inside and watch a movie if you
want to do that but don't forget that
there's a lot of beauty in our planet
just outside the window pursue
meaningful distractions so and I want to
stress meaningful if if at all possible
what we found when we were flying
astronauts to the space station at the
beginning I was working in the control
center as the Capcom talking to them and
they're like God they have a lot of
audience and they're not as much to do
here are there and what are they going
to do they're up there for a long time
and so there was different ideas like
they could take inventory and count how
many bags of ravioli they have left
stuff like that that's not necessarily
very meaningful what we found was a
better activity to do was to come up
with a hobby something that you really
enjoyed in your free time when you're up
there for that long so a lot of the
astronauts on the space station got into
photography that's like the best thing
you could do probably up there we have
some great cameras you have the most
beautiful scene you've ever seen looking
down on our planet and so they got into
photography and different techniques and
how to do
the time-lapse stuff so you can do
orbits and fly into the aurora some got
into doing artwork so i'm going to play
music but you you want to have something
that you find to be what I would say a
meaningful distraction so find yourself
a meaningful distraction put the time to
good use
stay connected I think we have lots of
ways now that we didn't have years ago
to help us stay connected to what's
going on and to each other in space we
were concerned about being far away and
not connected with what's going on with
the world and our families but we were
able to do things like email just like
you've been paired at home we have
computers in space and checking our
flight plans do we need to do it I also
can check my email I've already got some
email from my wife and my kids and it's
great to be able to stay
videoconferences in social media I was
the first one to ever send a tweet from
space and I was thrilled that they asked
me to do that because it gave me a way
to help with staying connected I could
share what I was doing so I think that
that's really important checking on
people that that you care about and also
tell me what you're doing you share your
your day with people let them know
what's happening stay connected being
back on earth
an interesting transition I was so
concerned about my mission for so long
four years and in it we flew the
missions and after each one I was happy
that they went well and it was a little
disappointed that they were over in some
ways and you get back to Earth and you
start realizing the things that you
missed and what I thought about when I
was away when I was in space I thought a
lot about my family I missed things like
the weather there's no rain or wind or
snow and or anything like that in space
is beautiful but you miss some of those
things and so what I found is after I
got back to earth I just wanted to be
around people he just was so grateful
that I was back and I could be doing the
things that I really enjoyed and around
the people I really loved again I never
complained about the weather anymore I
kind of liked the rain we don't have
that in space
but we have it here and we kind of take
it for granted I think I think this is
kind of similar to that right now I'm
supposed to be at opening day at Yankee
stick to you as I'm talking to you he's
in that even playing any baseball games
a new Lord knows when we're gonna get a
chance to do that and I haven't been
around a lot of my family members and I
miss a lot of people and big public
gatherings I miss all that stuff and I'm
sure you do too but we're gonna get over
this and a hopefully what it will do is
help us to appreciate what we have
during our good times and remember what
it's been like now all those things you
miss when you get back to doing them
make sure you really enjoy them and
don't take them for granted
that's one thing that I learned coming
back to earth as an astronaut the way I
found the best way to prepare for
missions and to do things was to hear
from other people that had done them and
what their experiences were so please we
have a comment section underneath all of
our videos and we would really
appreciate it if you gave us your
comments about maybe what you learned
from the video but also how you're
coping with your sheltering in place
because we all can learn from each other
and help each other out here in this
situations and also remember subscribe
to wired it doesn't even cost anything
you can watch all these videos and they
can spend your time in isolation
watching a bunch of Wired content so
please let us know how you're doing and
thanks for watching